Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Batman video we just
found out about some really cool Michael
Keaton Batman deleted scenes from crisis
on Infinite Earths because of some new
publications so we'll break it down
there's a ton of Easter eggs so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Easter Egg for Batman from
crisis on the video there were already a
bunch of Batman Easter eggs and cameo
scenes that made it into the final cut
of the episodes but some of these scenes
that the cutting room floor are
mind-blowing so number 5 recently a
bunch more deleted scenes in details
from crisis on Infinite Earths were
revealed the producers said they reached
out to almost every single movie and TV
actor who had played a major DC
character like Batman Superman Wonder
Woman Green Lantern you get the idea yes
they even reached out to Ryan Reynolds
for Green Lantern cameo scene you're
welcome Canada they were really trying
to get as many big iconic versions of
their most popular DC characters going
all the way back to the Adam West 1966
Batman series with the Burt Ward cameo
scene they went for some super deep cuts
But the time for preparation has past
the crisis is now upon us all. Holy crimson skies of death!
But when it comes to Michael Keaton deleted scenes
it was actually going to be a big
part of the storyline that he would have
been involved in it would have been way
more than just a brief cameo scene so
we'll explain what that alternate
storyline would have been had he
appeared in the episode Michael Keaton
obviously making the rounds again as The
Dark Knight because of all the DC movie
news in the flash flashpoint movie I've
already made a couple videos about that
but Michael Keaton is coming back as his
older Batman from the multiverse inside
the flash movie and he's going to cross
over into other future DC movies but
he's playing an older version of his
Batman from the Tim Burton movies the
Burton verse as most fans call those
movies so number four everybody saw the
version of the Michael Keaton cameo
scene during the opening scene of
episode 1
crisis on Infinite Earths featuring
Batman's earth 89 because that was the
year his first Batman movie came out
because now the entire multiverse is
about to come under attack
there is a malevolent force at work one
driven by a singular goal so that was
Robert wuhl who played Alexander Knox in
those Batman movies he worked for the
Gotham newspaper and that's why he's
reading the same newspaper from the
movie with the headline Batman catches
Joker one of the first Michael Keaton
deleted scenes would have been paying
off this alternate newspaper headline
here waynetech CEO Bruce Wayne to marry
socialite Selina Kyle the picture looks
like it's supposed to be sometime after
the events of Batman Returns the funny
thing about Michael Keaton appearing in
the flash flashpoint movie is the older
Batman is that they're actually supposed
to be sort of sidestepping the Joel
Schumacher Batman films in explaining
what Keaton's Batman has been doing
since the ending of Batman Returns so
obviously in this first deleted scene
they would have addressed that in some
way I also think they were going to use
this to link his Batman to the birds of
prey series from the early 2000s because
they had a big cameo scene with Huntress
during that too and Oracle Barbara Gordon
she was only on the comms but this was
the actress that played Batgirl on that
series there's a new version of Batgirl
that's going to appear on Titan season 3
but they haven't started filming that
yet the version of the Huntress on that
series was the daughter of Batman and
Catwoman there were some other details
during this first Batman scene though
that were a little off some continuity
errors and inconsistencies I think it
had something to do with the full
version of the new Michael Keaton Batman
deleted scene what that was supposed to
be too because that was going to be in a
completely different episode some of you
probably noticed these the first time
the episode aired the symbol shining in
the bat-signal isn't Michael Keaton's
Batman symbol it looks more like a
combination of the Batwoman symbol mixed
with the Batman Beyond symbol but this
is what the Batman Beyond symbol looks
like so that's not what they're going
for we don't know what year this is
supposed to be but if they were going to
include this younger version of Batman
in this other part of the scene that I'm
assuming that this is meant to take
place right after the events of the
first or second Batman movie and that's
why he's reading the newspaper that says
Batman catches Joker because he caught
the Joker in the late 80s if you're
assuming that that movie took place in
1989 my assumption with the weird Batman
symbol is that it's probably because
Michael Keaton backed out Warner
Brothers probably told them they weren't
allowed to use Keaton's Batman symbol
and outside of a Batman cameo a joke
easter-egg would be the biggest thing
that you can include so they probably
just said budget nobody's going to question
it that much they're just going to enjoy
seeing Batman and Joker stuff on screen
is the multiverse and they could be
vague about what year this is taking
place number three the second huge
Michael Keaton deleted scene is actually
much much bigger prolly cooler because
it would have been a big story arc
during crisis there were new materials
from the production that were released
this past week is part of the new crisis
book that they're selling for the
production with a bunch of original art
and storyboards showing Michael Keaton
as a Kingdom Come Batman Beyond version
of the character it just blows my mind
how cool would this have been had they
been able to include him in the actual
episode this way don't get me wrong
Kevin Conroy is amazing as Batman I love
that he got to play a live-action Batman
finally even though I wasn't super happy
with what they did with that version of
Batman on screen in the story but it's
clear now from all these details that
what they originally intended on doing
was giving that whole storyline to
Michael Keaton's Batman and either he
would have had to cameo scenes or they
would have rearranged things and he
would have just been part of this one
episode in this huge story line with the
Paragons but in episode 2 instead of
traveling to earth 99 for Batman Beyond
easter-egg they would have just traveled
to earth 89 and it would have been
mostly the same story because a look at
the Batcave here it's a combination of a
bunch of different classic bat caves the
consoles here with all the buttons on
them that look like they're old-timey
are from the Adam West's 1966 Batcave
but look here underneath this tarp is
the Michael Keaton Batmobile from the
first Batman movie so clearly they had
been planning on doing
Keaton Batman the whole time now there
was a lot of other stuff that they
included as part of the Kingdom Come
Easter eggs so they never referenced
Superman or the Justice League during
the Keaton Batman movies but in context
this older Batman had killed his
Superman and his Joker as well as the
rest of his rogues gallery of villains
so he was kind of the darkest timeline
version of Batman like his quote says
battle not with monsters lest he become
a monster which I believe was a Batman V
Superman quote I don't know if I would
have liked to have seen Michael Keaton
as a darkest timeline Batman as it
stands I wasn't really happy with the
darkest timeline Kevin Conroy Batman
when his Batman from the animated series
is probably one of the most nuanced and
righteous versions of the character
remember from Batman Beyond in the first
episode where he essentially hung up the
cape and cowl because he was forced to
resort to using a gun because he had a
heart attack and that was the only way
he could defeat the villains then you
have darkest timeline Batman who just
mowed through every single villain and a
lot of the heroes it sounds like too.
Clark oh he said yes anyone with the
badge or a flag life only makes sense if
you force it but I think what was
happening at the time is Michael Keaton
was probably in early talks with Warner
Brothers to come back in the movies is
Batman so that probably hurt the chances
of them actually pulling off Michael
Keaton during crisis on Infinite Earths
and the producers said that they didn't
get any extra budget for casting for
cameos or anything like that so a lot of
the actors that they went to the movie
actors did ask for money that they
couldn't pay or they just had really big
scheduling problems and couldn't
actually make the days that they wanted
them so yes they did reach out to Henry
Cavill Superman
Ben Affleck Batman gal gadot Wonder
Woman Christian Bale's Batman even
though they all said no they were able
to get Azra Miller which is probably one
of the best surprises of the whole
crossover now you can say that the
Justice League DC EU movies are cannon
to the arrowverse multiverse hopefully
we'll see Grant Gustin cameo in the
flash flashpoint movie next year even if
he's only there for two seconds it'd be
really really cool but number one
Michael Keaton is supposed to show up in
that flash movie the news reports about
his crossover make it sound like he's
not going to be in the entire movie but
because his new Batman contract hasn't
crossing over into other future DC
movies eventually doing a Batman Beyond
movie hopefully they'll probably have
some sort of post-credit scene with him
that references continued adventures
across the multiverse or he'll get stuck
on the main earth of the Justice League
movie or they'll have some loose
flashpoint explanation so that he
doesn't have to jump back and forth
between Earth's every single time he
shows up in a new DC movie there were
only loosely basing the plot of the
flash movie on flashpoint it won't be
exactly like the comic book flashpoint
and just to be clear they're not
replacing Ben Affleck's Batman with a
flashpoint twist so Michael Keaton will
still be a different Batman Ben Affleck
will still canonically be the bat
of this earth robert pattinson 'he's
Batman is also not going to replace Ben
Affleck's Batman either there's a whole
lot of Batman that's going to be flying
around next year so it's a good time to
be a Batman fan if you are a huge fan of
the franchise there might be a couple
small flashpoint details that they used
to retcon things but it's not going to be
like them just erasing Ben Affleck from
the timeline so people that are worried
about that or want Ben Affleck to come
back don't worry I did just do a new
video about his Batman because of all
the reports lately about him coming back
to do Batman stuff for the Justice
League Snyder cut so you can actually
click here to watch those and you can
click here for that brand new stranger
things season 4 trailer thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!